this is from the daily wire says film
director Darren Aronofsky is defending
his choice to cast actor Brendan Frazier
to play an obese gay man in the Golden
Globe nominated drama the whale the
movie tells the story of Charlie a
middle-aged man who gains weight
following the death of his boyfriend and
works on repairing the relationships
with his estranged daughter it received
critical Acclaim but one common reaction
in the Hollywood Community was to
question whether Frasier was the best
choice for the role given that he's not
actually gay or obese
said he was surprised by the reaction
but still stands behind his decision he
said the film director said actors have
been using makeup since the beginning of
acting that's one of their tools and the
lengths we went to portray the realism
of the makeup has never been done before
one of my first calls after casting
Brendan was to my makeup artist I asked
him can we do something that realistic
because it's going to look like a joke
if it's going to look like a joke then
we shouldn't do it
this is the kind of thing I was I was I
was way when I heard this about this
film was coming out and it is getting
some some awards buzz and some some
critical acclaim
and I thought like are they actually
going to be able to get away with this
now I have no issue with it
and it sounds like an interesting idea
uh put take Brendan Fraser uh and put
him in like in the fat suit and try to
pull off an actual dramatic performance
sounds interesting to me
and I'll probably give it a watch when
it uh when it's available on streaming
but I was wondering can are can are can
you get away with this now are you
allowed to even do this
because he's not actually morbidly obese
so they put him in the fat suit
and then I didn't even realize until I
just read the article but apparently
he's portraying a gay man
and he's not gay
so not only do you have the
appropriation claim but then also is it
it's uh is it is it body shaming you
know because if you're going to have a
dramatic story about a morbidly obese
person
a lot of the drama is going to be
grounded in the fact that it's not
good to be morbidly obese like this is
something that he's suffering with this
I would think that that's how it's
portrayed it's not it's not gonna be a
portrayed like he's not gonna be dancing
to lizzo's songs the whole the whole
film okay he's not going to be giving I
I assume he's not going to be giving
speeches on uh body acceptance and fat
acceptance and all the rest of it
so can you do that in modern Hollywood
and it turns out
and
maybe sort of but not really
because the backlash I guess it took a
little bit while for the backlash to
generate but now it's finally here and
of course it's completely ridiculous
I mean the the value if there's any
value to acting as an art form
and I think there is by the way
you know when it's done well it is it is
a true art form and uh it's it can be a
very powerful art form
but I think one of the things again when
done well one of the things that makes
it so powerful is that it's uh it's
it's empathy you know acting is it's
almost empathy as an art form because
you you have to inhabit someone else who
isn't you and
you know sort of try to understand their
motivations and and inhabit that
character I don't know I'm not an actor
myself but that seems like that's kind
of the process
which is why for so long before we got
into this obsession with with
appropriation and representation all
this nonsense
it's
usually the critically acclaimed
performances are the ones that where an
actor is portraying something that's
much further away from who he actually
is
that's that's when you're the most
impressed
you're not impressed with the fact that
an actor is portraying something very
similar to what they already are
there might be a certain skill involved
in that but when you could put an actor
in a role that's the total opposite of
of them
and they pull it off
then that's the whole art that's what
the that's what the art is
and it's a good thing because it's it's
empathy to put Brendan Fraser in a fat
suit and have him really pull off that
performance and uh turn them into a
protagonist that you kind of feel for
and root for that shows that he has
empathies he's understanding people who
struggle with obesity
so it should be something we celebrated
but oftentimes it's not
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign